chers collègues je suis vraiment très
heureuse d'accueillir à présent le
professeur jean sibilia doyen de la
faculté de médecine de strasbourg
président du comité scientifique locale
merci de tout coeur chers gens d'avoir
répondu à mon invitation et d'avoir près
de votre temps précieux pour venir faire
ici devant les conseillers
départementaux du rhin un point sur la
situation sanitaire
les enjeux des prochaines semaines les
préconisations aussi est aussi et
surtout pour répondre à nos questions
permettez moi également de vous
remercier pour votre engagement précieux
localement dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire inédite et merci pour
votre disponibilité
lorsque j'ai eu à vous consulter sur
certaines décisions que nous avons mises
en oeuvre en effet tout au long des
dernières semaines
vous nous avez accompagné quand je dis
nous c'est l'ensemble des collectivités
alsaciennes passe à l'inconnu et face à
des choix importants nous connaissant
depuis longtemps nous avons eu à
travailler sur certains projets
d'envergure internationale et ses
projets d'envergure internationale c'est
ici en alsace que voulait développer
ah si vous avez été immédiatement
disponible lorsque nous avons souhaité
vous consulté durant cette crise
notamment concernant le dépistage dans
les ehpad et l'interprétation de ces
dépistages vos éclairages ont été pour
nous une véritable aide à l'appréhension
de tous les enjeux et à la décision
j'ai aussi vu que dans un article du
monde paru hier vous revenez sur
l'engagement exemplaire est incroyable
des personnels de santé notamment des
étudiants en santé mobilisés par
l'épidémie
pour qui cette crise a pris la forme
d'un véritable parcours initiatique dans
l'adversité
vraiment profiter de votre présence pour
leur rendre hommage
leur dire notre respect notre
reconnaissance ainsi qu'à tous ceux
comme vous que les encadrer et les
former cette crise aura promis en
lumière la vocation et l'engagement dans
son acception la plus forte
l'action dans les hôpitaux dans les
ehpad de ces jeunes et de l'ensemble des
soignants m'évoque belles phrases dans
gran alsacien c'est le prix nobel albert
schweitzer
il disait que chacun s'efforce dans le
milieu où il se trouve
de témoigner à d'autres une véritable
humanité
c'est de cela que dépend l'avenir du
monde alors je serai pas plus longue
pour vous laisser le plus de temps
possible
nous avons convenu que vous ne feriez
une présentation d'environ un quart
d'heure vingt minutes maximum ensuite il
nous laissait entre 20 minutes et une
demi-heure maximum pour autant de
questions réponses
monsieur le doyen grand merci pour votre
présence à vous la parole
merci beaucoup brigitte merci pour ces
très très gentil mot qui est voilà qui
forcément qui me qui me touche parce que
dans ces moments extrêmement difficiles
on se serre les coudes et des relations
pleine de bienveillance et pleine de
respect mutuel je crois qu'elles font du
bien les athéniens peu toutes les
difficultés qu'on a tous ensemble et je
pense que comme vous l'avez dit un des
points qu'on souligne tous aujourd'hui
c'est cet engagement de toussaint ou au
profit de nos citoyens de de notre notre
alsace 2 et 9 pays et je pense que c'est
la plus belle des choses qu'on est vieux
on l'a tous observé et surtout chez vous
dans le haut rhin
puisque vous avez été malheureusement
payé un lourd tribut en fait à cette
épidémie bien plus qu'ailleurs et vous
avez été absolument extraordinaire dans
l'adversité et jeu j'en profiterais
comme je le fais à chaque fois que je
prends la parole pour féliciter
remercier chaleureusement du fond du
coeur non seulement les soignants
évidemment parce qu'ils ont été en
première ligne ceux de l'hôpital
et je le répète ça a été tellement
difficile chez vous dans le haut rhin à
mulhouse et à colmar mais aussi tous
ceux qui ont été sur le terrain on les
oublie peut-être un tout petit peu mais
je voulais témoigner et les remercier
les médecins généralistes qui ont
vraiment été en grande difficulté mais
aussi les médecins spécialistes parce
que peux témoigner que certains ont
fermé leur cabinet et ont demandé à
venir aider à l'hôpital ce qui est aussi
un acte absolument incroyable donc
vraiment tous ces soignants que ceux de
l'hôpital soit de la vivent
et puis tous les citoyens qui nous ont
aidés faut rappeler que alors c'est
parce que on y habite dans un village
mais voilà ma boulangère mon le celui
qui tient le commerce etc
tous les gens qui ont participé à la vie
la vie citoyenne de tous les jours ils
sont autant et je le dis sans aucune
démagogie ils sont autant héros de ce
moment là parce que ils ont dû surmonter
leurs peurs surmonter leurs difficultés
et est finalement moi je suis un petit
peu heureux pour mes troupes
mais gêné gêné à 20 heures tous les
soirs quand on nous applaudit et parce
que les soignants sont là c'est notre
c'est juste ce qu'on doit faire on n'est
pas des héros on est juste là parce que
c'est notre place notre métier et je
suis heureux qu'on le reconnaisse mais
je veux pas qu'on dise qu'on ait des
héros parce qu'on n'est pas plus des
héros que les gens qui ont qui ont
ramassé les poubelles en fait c'est
courage et aussi un à chacun sa tâche et
s'est sans aucune démagogie
le gîte me connaissez je peux vous dire
que c'est vraiment très sincère et c'est
le moment de resserrer les liens et pas
que entre les soignants et la population
mais au sein de toute notre population
et je le répète
bravo et fierté à tous les haut rhinois
et les alsaciens parce que on sait on a
été très solidaire et strasbourg s'est
beaucoup engagée auprès de d du haut
rhin pour vous aider à la fois pour
accueillir les malades en réanimation
pour soutenir toutes les actions qu'on a
mené et qu'on continue à mener et je
pense qu'il faut absolument dans le
monde
on aime bien dire dans le monde de
demain alors le nom de demain il sera
pas non plus idyllique on va pas en
crise est pas simplement en tournant le
bouton le monde de 2001 mais je pense
qu'il sera quand même pas pareil il ne
sera pas complètement transformé mais on
ne reviendra pas non plus à ce qu'on a
vécu avant et tirons le meilleur
et on pourrait citer beaucoup de phrases
elle est magnifique injaz connaissait
pas à celle d'albert schweitzer mais
merci brigitte de me l'envoyer parce que
je le répèterai mais essayons de garder
le meilleur et il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire à la fois sur le sur le terrain
dans nos territoires dont nos hôpitaux
dans notre système de santé dans notre
société et même au delà je suis très
sensible à une dimension que qui nous
touche nous en alsace qui est la
dimension européenne
très sensible à la solidarité de nos
voisins qui nous ont quand même donné un
sacré coup de pouce mais j'allais dire
quasiment à l'amicale sur le terrain et
regretté peut-être que l'europe de la
santé là je suis en train de rédiger un
texte une tribune pour un grand journal
sur l'europe de la santé parce que je
pense qu'on peut faire beaucoup mieux et
que donner un sens à l'europe de la
santé s'est donné un sens spots est à la
solidarité européenne et et et justes
dans cette fin d'introduction vous dire
que moi je suis né dans les années 60 et
j'ai jamais vu qu de guerre mais mes
parents et mes grands parents l'ont
vécue et j'aimerais transmettre à mes
enfants in europe et est solidaire sur
les piliers d'une europe qui sont la
santé qui sont la protection des
citoyens
et puis tout ce qu'on peut considérer
comme le des règles de vie ensemble de
règles sociales qui sont la justice et
d'éducation si on pouvait partager ça ça
donnerait peut-être un sens nouveau à
une solidarité différentes et nous
l'alsace on est au coeur du coeur du
dispositif c'est pour ça que me
permettait d'évoquer ce point qui me
paraît extrêmement important donc en
conclusion dans l'introduction générale
merci franchement aux haut-rhinoises
lady à mulhouse la semaine dernière mais
c'est vraiment merci pour votre votre
combativité et puis essayons maintenant
de retrouver de retrouver nos pas une
vie on va en parler une vie normale
parce qu'elle va être différente
quelques mois j'espère uniquement
quelques mois et pas quelques années
mais on va essayer de s'adapter ensemble
et de tirer le meilleur et qu'il n'y ait
pas de retour de manivelle voiliers de
règlements de comptes entre guillemets
on entend déjà par ci par là des comptes
qu'il faut régler moi je ne suis pas du
tout partisan de régler des comptes il
n'y a pas de comptes à régler
il ya à avancer ensemble on tire les
leçons de ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a
bien fait et de ce qu'on a mal fait on
règle pas de compte mais on avance
ensemble et on donne un sens nouveau à
notre vivre ensemble et
retour en alsace puisque on y tient et
si on est là ensemble c'est parce que on
a cette sensibilité là et cette
solidarité là elle est nationale on est
français mais on est aussi on a cette
solidarité alsacienne qui me paraît
extrêmement extrêmement importante voilà
brigitte quelques mots d'introduction
pour évoquer avec vous après trois
sujets essentiels pour essayer de faire
le point sur le la situation de
l'épidémie kovy 19 actuelle et puis pour
répondre évidemment aux questions la
première question que vous vous posez
tous certainement et nous aussi et tous
les experts c'est on sort du des
contenants sort du confinement
nous passons dans une phase un peu
intermédiaire dit de déconfinement
progressif évidemment selon la
circulation du virus et de la saturation
du système de santé qui sont les deux
critères utilisés comment est ce que on
va vivre les prochains mois et quel est
le risque de cette fameuse deuxième
vague donc vous dire que aujourd'hui les
modèles sont sur la table
il ya eu plein de modélisation qui ont
été faites sur la base de ce qu'on sait
c'est à dire la connaissance du virus sa
contagiosité l'efficacité des mesures
barrières qui casse la transmission du
virus
ce qu'on a pu les mesures et pendant les
confinements en france et ailleurs donc
on a pas mal d'éléments aujourd'hui pour
simuler ce qu'il se passera dans
quelques semaines à quelques mois
mais évidemment aucune certitude ça
c'est un premier point
aucun modèle aujourd'hui ne permet
raisonnablement de prédire ce qui va se
passer et ça c'est comme un point
important ces terres que la science est
là et c'est un exemple pour essayer
d'éclairer ce qu'on devra faire
d'éclairer les décisions des politiques
et là aussi j'en profite pour pour bien
expliquer ce que je dis à chaque fois
nous faisons partie des experts mon
travail a été de fédérer un peu
l'expertisé parmi ma communauté
universitaire d'essayer de tirer cette
expertise vers le haut de d'accumuler
connaissances pour essayer d'éclairer
des décisions des décisions qui sont
celles des politiques
un expert ne décide pas un expert essaye
de donner de dire tout ce qu'il fait est
ce qu'il ne sait pas pour que les
politiques puissent prendre les
meilleures décisions possibles en
l'occurrence tous les experts du monde
dans tous les pays du monde ont essayé
de faire des simulations on l'a fait en
france ça a été fait très récemment par
un article publié hier par l'institut
pasteur qui a donné des simulations et
l'état de l'art et les simulations en
france aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
prédire ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains mois néanmoins ce qu'on sait
sur l'expérience des virus respiratoires
comme la grippe ou d'autres virus
respiratoires
on sait que généralement ces virus
respiratoires qui sont plus ou moins
sensibles à la chaleur ou au froid on
appelle ça les virus froid un
code-barres istres et l'équipe des
russes froid sont ni virus qui ont ces
virus respiratoires qui ont très souvent
une deuxième phase où plusieurs phases
de ressurgissent ans à partir de
l'automne de l'hiver et l'année qui suit
ça c'est le modèle habituel donc toutes
les simulations et les calculs sont
fondés sur ce qu'on sait de ce type de
virus qui n'est pas commis de 19 mais
qui sont des virus comparables et à
partir de là on peut imaginer qu'il y
aura effectivement des vagues petites ou
grandes
et c'est toute la question à l'automne à
l'hiver boire avant peut-être même au
cours de l'été je ne vais pas vous
décrire les modèles de simulation mais
vous dire que schématiquement il ya des
simulations optimiste et des simulations
pessimiste et que évidemment ces
simulations
elles sont conditionnées par trois
facteurs pour faire simple le premier
facteur c'est le facteur directement lié
au virus lui même et ça vous savez très
bien que ce virus
on vient de découvrir en début d'année
on ne le connaissait pas donc là la vie
de ce virus
c'est à dire sa sensibilité à la chaleur
la vie de ce virus c'est-à-dire sa
capacité à muter mais dans les deux sens
ce type de virus quand des virus
on appelle à arn le petit code génétique
à l'intérieur s'appelle la rn6 vers eux
aussi peuvent muter donc peu mais ils
peuvent muter dans un sens de
l'aggravation ou de l'amélioration
donc on peut imaginer aussi des
mutations qu'on appelle à des pertes de
virulence série à meyrin des virus qui
deviennent un virus qui deviendrait
moins dangereux ça déjà été observés
donc cette vie du virus
sa sensibilité à la chaleur et à
l'humidité à la saison chaude entre
guillemets et sa sensibilité sa
variation par des mutations génétiques
on ne la connaît pas aujourd'hui on a
purement des spéculations mais on n'en
connaît pas ça c'est comme un facteur
fondamental et concernant ce virus
on a 1 2
un point majeur c'est de savoir comment
il va entraîner l'immunisation des
populations cette immunisation des
populations vous savez qu'elle est assez
modeste
aujourd'hui puisque les chiffres
montrent que en france c'est autour de
5% de la population qui a été en contact
du virus en contact qui les effets ou
non les symptômes à peu près 5%
on peut estimer que dans le grand est a
fortiori dans le haut rhin et en alsace
on est pro mais en plus tôt entre 10 et
et 15 pour ce temps et on verra les
chiffres un peu plus généraux quand les
enquêtes générales sont est donc on est
très supérieur à la moyenne nationale
mais ça n'est quand même que 10 à 15% de
la population qui a rencontré le virus
en d'autres termes si c'est 10 à 15 % 90
à 85 % ne l'a pas rencontré
donc ce qui fait donc que le virus pour
der circuler dans cette population
n'ayant jamais vu le virus et c'est ça
qui qui expose en fait à ce risque ne
ressurgisse ans et 2e blague c'est que
il ya encore un grand nombre de nos
citoyens nos concitoyens qui n'ont pas
rencontré
malheureusement ce colis 19 donc voilà
ce qu'on peut dire sur ce premier point
avec toutes les incertitudes de la
biologie du virus et de la réponse des
gens qui le rencontre avec évidemment
pour compléter ce que ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui de nombreux travaux en cours
des travaux qui ont été menés par vaux
brigitte dans le haut rhin pour essayer
de mieux connaître de façon détaillée la
séroprévalence c'est à dire la présence
d'anticorps chez nous citoyens mais
aussi comprendre comment ces anticorps
de gens qui ont fait la maladie son
protecteur durablement ou pas
durablement
donc on a toutes cette question de ces
questions scientifiques médicales et
scientifiques qu'on est en train
d'étudier notamment à strasbourg avec
mon ami samir un chapitre est maire on
est en train d'étudier la réponse
anticorps la réponse immunitaire des
sujets essayer de la comprendre parce
qu'elle permettra d'anticiper la suite
et peut-être d'ailleurs de développer
des stratégies thérapeutiques
vous avez bien compris que si on
comprend on connaît mieux ce virus et on
connaît mieux ses conséquences
immunitaire on pourra en tirer des
conséquences thérapeutique
c'est à dire des médicaments et on sait
déjà qu aujourd'hui par exemple traiter
les patients avec du sérum de sujets
convalescent permet d'améliorer détente
grands voiliers cette année
ample qui montre que la connaissance du
virus et de la réponse immunitaire peut
nous aider
évidemment nous aidera pour la
vaccination ce qui me permet j'en
parlerai de faire plus tard un petit
focus sur la vaccination qui a fait
couler beaucoup d'encre là depuis depuis
ça c'est la première variable c'est
l'avis du virus la biologie du virus et
la réponse immunitaire qu'il induit
c'est une première variable hyper
importante ne connaît pas tous de cette
variable là elle est déterminante pour
savoir comment va se passer mon se
passer les prochaines semaines la
deuxième par iab qui fondamentale et
c'est peut-être celle qui est encore
plus importante pour nous pour les
citoyens c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'état en l'absence de vaccination
en l'absence de traitements antiviraux
efficaces déterminer de façon certaine
aujourd'hui la seule réponse à
l'épidémie ce sont les mesures dites
barrière ça c'est fondamental
il faut le rappeler on a le comité
scientifique a rédigé un texte que je
vous enverrai brigide qui sera
disponible je pense lundi où on rappelle
ce que je viens de vous dire sur la vie
du virus est ce que je vais vous dire
sur les mesures barrières
elles sont fondamentales je répète parce
qu'elles sont la seule réponse efficace
des montrer efficace aujourd'hui contre
cette épidémie
ces mesures barrières elles sont
extrêmement simple il y en a une qui est
simplement mettre de la distance entre
les individus
puisque ce virus un virus est un petit
parasite bien méchant qui ne vit ce
petit virus que s'il se transmet d'un
homme à un autre
le virus ne vit pas plus de quelques
heures ou quelques jours
en dehors d'un organisme vivant c'est à
dire effectivement on peut avoir un peu
de virus sur des surfaces inerte sur des
surfaces humides sont même sur du papier
mais ça ne durera que quelques heures à
quelques jours
en revanche s'il se transmet d'homme à
homme il poursuit sa vie indéfiniment
donc on veut casser ce qu'on appelle la
contagiosité entre les humains et on met
de la distance au moins un mètre à un
mètre cinquante
pourquoi pour une raison simple
aujourd'hui qui est très clair c'est que
ce virus se transmet à la fois par voie
respiratoire par les petits postillons
est-ce qu'on projette les postillons
d'un sujet infecté
si elles rejoignent le nez la bouche ou
les yeux elles sont capables de
transmettre le virus même à distance
dans une distance inférieure à 1 m à 1 m
50 donc la première mesure c'est garder
une forme de distance
le terme distance physique que
distanciation social que je trouve trop
compliqué et pas très joli mais il faut
une distance physique de l'ordre de
mettre un peu plus quand on court ça
c'est une chose intéressante qu'on a
appris un joggeur ou un coureur à
l'exercice physique projette les
particules un peu plus loin quand il
respire très fort et ça il faut le
savoir notamment dans le cadre de
l'ouverture départs potentiels
voyez c'est un exemple appliquer aux
mesures citoyenne et au développement de
de la phase de déconfinement si on
ouvrait les parcs
il ne faudrait pas autorisée par exemple
les joggeurs à passer au milieu de la
population c'est un exemple qui montre
que la science qu'on a appris peut
servir à la décision quotidienne
l'addition qu'on peut prendre pour nos
citoyens donc mesures barrières la
distance
deuxième mesure très importante c'est et
je la mets en volontiers en deuxième
point c'est se laver les mains
régulièrement
clairement on a aujourd'hui beaucoup
d'arguments pour penser que la première
contamination
c'est pas la projections de gouttelettes
d'un sujet infecté un autre trop la
projection de postillons sur les yeux le
nez la bouche mais c'est plus nos
propres mains qui vont toucher les
surfaces infectées par le virus et qui
machinalement vient de se porter à notre
nez notre bouche et nos yeux on peut
estimer mais c'est un chiffre qui est
peut-être artificiel mais que 80% des
contaminations se font de façon manu
portet sais vous allez toucher quelque
chose qui ait souillé par du virus que
vous ne voyez pas évidemment qui peut
être votre table qui peut être un bouton
d'ascenseur qu'il peut être un banc qui
peut être quelque chose tout ce qui est
susceptible d'être souillé par du virus
et puis vous allez porter instantanément
et de façon inconsciente les mains au
visage
on le fait tout le temps essayez de
regarder on est tout le temps en train
de se boucher le nez les yeux et c'est
assez machinal l'homme est comme ça il
se reconnaît lui même probablement en
touchant son visage
et ça c'est très contaminant donc il
faut se laver les mains en permanence
il faut acquérir une forme de réflexes
qui est ce dur chaque fois que j'ai
touché quelque chose qui est susceptible
d'être infecté dans l'espace public et
je me lave les mains vieux mais du gel
hydro hydroalcoolique
ça c'est très très important troisième
mesure on en a beaucoup beaucoup parlé
c'est une mesure fondamentale dans
l'espace public c'est protéger les voies
respiratoires par
barrière donc c'est simple je pense
qu'on a très mal expliqué le problème au
départ parce que c'est un virus
respiratoires et quand on est confronté
à une épidémie de virus respiratoires
une des premières mesures
c'est de mettre une barrière sur les
voies respiratoires donc à masquer hamas
alors le masque il est utile dans toutes
les conditions
à l'hôpital en réanimation mais aussi
aujourd'hui dans malheureusement
peut-être mais dans la dans la vie
civile au quotidien et à fortiori dans
toutes les situations où les mesures
simples de distance ne sont pas
respectables tout le temps je pense à
des choses très simples là le passage
dans la rue les commerces peut-être
demain on verra dans les restaurants
c'est une vraie question à chaque fois
que le mètre le mètre cinquante ne pas
être respecté il faut absolument mettre
un masque parce que là où protégez-vous
voies respiratoires donc ces trois
mesures la la distance
le lavage des mains extrêmement régulier
et le port d'un masque à chaque fois
qu'il n'y a plus de respect des mesures
barrières c'est absolument fondamental
c'est la seule réponse aujourd'hui
d'aidé montré absolument efficace dans
cette épidémie
la dernière mesure mais je la mets à
part c'est très particulier mais il faut
le rappeler c'est pas agréable
c'est évidemment le confinement de tout
sujet infecté ou de tout sujet suspect
d'être infectés c'est vrai beaucoup
aujourd'hui si on veut casser les
kloster vous avez compris le terme et la
contagiosité il faut absolument qu'on
soit capable de dépister et d'isoler
évidemment c'est tous les sujets
infectés de leur permettre de guérir
sans contaminer d'autres su ça c'est
vraiment important et on l'a rappelé il
faut le rappeler et faut relayer dans
une vision et pour conclure sur ce
deuxième point dans une vision qui est
extrêmement en tout cas nous c'est la
recommandation qu'on donne dans une
vision extrêmement citoyenne solidaire
généreuse et responsable je pense que
c'est les mots clés sont un manteau on
doit pas être dans une vision
coercitives
notre société n'est pas construite comme
ça il ya des sociétés où c'est plus
acceptable quand on voit la corée la
corée
non pas du nord et du sud même des suds
je prends pas la corée du nord mais où
il ya eu zéro manade zéro infection mais
là c'est un petit clin d'oeil aussi la
chance qu'on a de vivre en démocratie
avec un sens de la liberté d'information
que
pays non pas au niveau où on la remet
même en corée du sud
le tracking ses terres le suivi des
malades
la coercition imposé dans des sociétés
aux asiatiques n'est pas transposable
aux nôtres donc nous on doit agir sur
les leviers qu'on connaît c'est à dire
moi je crois profondément à ça sur la
responsabilisation individuelle et
collective en rappelant que quand on
fait ça quand on applique ces mesures
barrières on se protège soit mais
surtout on protège les autres c'est ça
qui est important c'est comme la
vaccination et on oublie de le dire je
le regrette mais la vaccination contre
la grippe ou j'espère un jour contre le
koro est un geste citoyen de générosité
de protection des autres os protège les
autres donc je crois qu'il faut agir
je répète responsabilisation expliqué
que c'est de la générosité explique sexe
et du civisme sanitaire qui est
aujourd'hui indispensable
et ça il faut y mettre de la pédagogie
la recommandation qu'on a fait
j'ai fait à strasbourg à plusieurs
reprises ces accompagnons les citoyens
pour leur expliquer qu'il faut faire ça
pour eux et pour les autres plutôt que
de les verbaliser dans l'espace public
ou dans les transports
c'est leur donner un masque et que ceux
qui ne l'ont pas plutôt que de les punir
c'est leur expliquer leur dire pourquoi
il faut qu'ils emportent et leur
randonnée ça c'est extrêmement important
voilà ça c'est vraiment un point le
point ce point 2 qui est majeure et que
je me suis permis dé taille et le poids
3 qui est fondamental parce qu'on est
dedans et vous y avez participé et
brigitte en anticipant et votre action
dans les ehpad
je les ai déjà dit à plusieurs reprises
été remarquable en fait parce que vous
avez pris les devants et qu' il est
important d'agir notamment au profit des
plus fragiles je pense que je vais vous
expliquer ça donc dans cette troisième
partie
il faut maintenant qu'on va sortir du
confinement il va falloir qu'on
accompagne déconfinement pour éviter la
deuxième vague c'est à dire la
contagiosité et a fortiori éviter la
contagion de nos plus fragiles pour une
raison extrêmement simple et ça ça
explique très bien la hiérarchie de ce
qu'il faut qu'on mette en place
parce que finalement le problème de ce
virus il n'est pas de tuer un grand
nombre de sujets vous avez vu les
chiffres de mortalité en fait quand on
prend les gens jeunes jusqu'à 59 ans
puisque la tranche on peut considérer
que jusqu'à 59 ans on est encore un
ces jeunes jusqu'à 59 ans le maximum de
mortalité dans les tranches d'âge et 0
2%
c'est peu au fond 1 par contre là où
c'est devient extrêmement embêtant c'est
sur les populations
au delà de 60 ans et d'amour au delà de
70 80 et que ça où la mortalité est très
très importante
or on tient à nos anciens qu'on aime
beaucoup c'est l'anniversaire de mon
papa aujourd'hui qui à 86 envoyez donc
il est on est adversaire le 15 mai et
voilà on tient à nos parents on tient
nos anciens c'est évident on les aime et
on a envie de les garder plus longtemps
possible mais au-delà de ça plus
collectivement le fait de préserver des
populations les plus fragiles c'est à
dire celles qui deviennent malades on va
préserver le système de santé parce que
notre problème est ce qui a mené au
confinement
c'est pas la gravité intrinsèque de ce
virus c'est le fait qu'il mène à
l'hôpital est en réanimation un grand
nombre de patients fragiles
c'est à dire des sujets âgés et des
sujets plus jeunes atteints de diabète
d'hypertension d'obésité et c'est donc
il faut vraiment si on est si on et
comment vous dire cohérent dans la
stratégie il faut éviter pour éviter un
deuxième confinement je crois tout à
fait possible éviter de contaminer les
populations les plus sensibles c'est à
dire celles qui sont le plus
susceptibles d'aller à l'hôpital et on
va une nation donc nos sujets âgés dont
les ehpad ceux qui vivent en
collectivité
les sujets avec des comorbidités où les
sujets qu'ils vivent confinement ans
travaillent dans des entreprises on
travaille dans des petits dans des
petits espaces
évidemment nos soignants qui sont une
des priorités dans le dispositif
donc je crois que les actions qu'on doit
mener un complément du dispositif
national qui est quand même on a
beaucoup critiqué le gouvernement les
collectivités et leurs capacités mais
mais quand vous regardez le dispositif
qui a été mis en place aujourd'hui avec
un nombre de détecteurs
en ambulatoire à l'hôpital le centre 15
sos médecins les laboratoires de
virologie quand on voit le dispositif de
détection tout azimut mis en place avec
les médecins généralistes dans un
système de coordination par nation ans
maladie on a fait tout ça en deux mois
ces femmes je suis dans le système de
santé depuis trente ans et c'est
inimaginable pour nous qu'on ait réussi
une organisation alors on jugera de son
efficacité bien sûr à distance mais
cette organisation elle est quand même
enfin assez remarquable au moins dans
son arborisation verra son efficacité
voilà ne présumons pas de des résultats
mais quand même on a mis en place
quelque chose de très important
impliquant évidemment les territoires et
ça ça me paraît fondamental il ne faut
pas travailler qu'avec l'hôpital quand
les balades arrive à l'hôpital c'est
trop tard c'est à dire que l'épidémie
est déjà parti dans les territoires donc
le travail aujourd'hui il est
fondamentalement a organisé avec des
territoires avec les médecins libéraux
les généralistes les autres avec les
soignants avec les structures médico
sociales avec les hôpitaux de proximité
parce que c'est comme ça qu on détectera
suffisamment tôt des transmissions des
réamorce de transmission virale
donc je crois que dispositif il est
intéressant mais évidemment on peut le
compléter nous dans nos territoires par
des initiatives territoriales
départementale c'est le cas dans les
ehpad
le brigitte vous avez donné l'exemple et
boyer le travail m'a emmené dans les
ehpad avec un double action on cherche
le virus mais on cherche des anticorps
il faut faire les deux certainement un
et de façon répétée par définition j'y
reviendrai peut-être donc on mène ces
actions aussi par des initiatives
départementales municipales et il faut
combiner les actions ne pensons pas
sortons de l'ancien monde où chacun fait
ce qu'il croit être bien aujourd'hui
mettons nous ensemble on doit se tenir
la main et mon ma démarche de coeur de
soignants et de doyen enfin
d'institutionnels et c'est un peu ma
mission c'est mon rôle est et c'est le
sens que je donne à sa c2 nous nous la
main tous ensemble pour la première fois
peut-être
et allons dans le sens chacun à sa place
l'expert il n'a pas à décider
l'expert il analyse je suis expert de
terreur jiwa des patients tous les jours
je
tout ce qui se publie enfin pas tous
évidemment mais beaucoup de choses je
partage avec mes collègues et je digère
ses connaissances là pour essayer
maintenant la main de travailler avec
les collectivités toutes les
collectivités et le réseau national et
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
gagner la bataille contre ce virus par
des actions en gros c'est comme c'est
comme à la pêche
voyez on gagnera le la bataille par un
filet dont les mailles sont suffisamment
petit pour capter ce virus qui est
microscopique on n'a pas besoin de maya
la taille du virus on a besoin de maille
à la taille de tous les gens qui peuvent
faire des symptômes et qui peut être
contaminants et je pense le pôle
important je le répète c'est d'accès le
les actions prioritaires sur les
populations les plus fragiles
je me répète c'est à dire nos anciens
les populations malades les populations
soignantes les populations exposées en
fait au public
si on fait ça moi je suis assez
optimiste mais je le dis souvent
optimisme souvent la répression que
l'optimisme c'est celui qui vit dans le
monde du bisounours et qui n'est pas
rigoureux qui a pas les pieds sur terre
on peut être optimiste mais rigoureux et
on n'est pas forcément rigoureux quand
on est pessimiste
donc je pense qu'ici on peut comprendre
dans le monde qu'on espère que le
l'optimisme et une vision de notre
société de notre nom de notre
organisation peut être optimiste avec
des valeurs partagées mais optimiste
avec de la rigueur et y mettre de la
rigueur
moi je suis assez aujourd'hui frappée en
tout cas dans ce que je vois alors j'ai
voyez j'ai regardé dans mon village dans
mon hôpital dans la rue je vois beaucoup
de gens jeunes moins jeunes de tout âge
qui portent masse qui font attention je
trouve que et c'est un un message
important et je pense qu'il faut
l'utiliser ce message on peut on doit
être fier de notre société nos citoyens
il faut leur dire ou pas tout le temps
taguer les choses en disant ou fait mal
vous faites pas bien vous n'écoutez pas
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de gens la
majorité qui font bien et qui ont envie
de bien faire et dans la pédagogie qu'on
doit développer dans cet accompagnement
territoriales il ya aussi une pédagogie
de dire regardez les chiffres
regardez oncle et bien voilà ça marche
et je suis sûr que si on fait ça on peut
s'en sortir sans une deuxième vague qui
reviendrait au niveau de la première
évidemment un expert n'est pas un devin
et surtout pas surtout pas ils le
l'expert n'a pas de conviction je ne
donne jamais ma conviction profonde
parce qu'on s'en fout au fond c'est pas
ça qui compte c'est ce que je sais est
ce que je ne sais pas donc aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas si on peut si on aura la
chance d'une période de deuxième vague
qui encourt à nouveau le système de
santé ce qui serait franchement très
compliqué à vivre
je ne sais pas en revanche ce que je
sais que si on travaille main dans la
main
si on se serre les coudes si on applique
les mesures barrières si on fait preuve
de générosité et de pédagogie
je suis certain qu'on peut qu'on peut y
arriver ensemble et même en alsace qui
malheureusement voilà une zone à haut
risque par définition puisque le virus a
beaucoup circulé chez nous c'est notre
région ne peut être qu à haut risque car
par définition
donc attention chez nous mais je sais
que je vais déjà racontée à plusieurs
reprises les les alsaciens ont une
capacité
l'histoire l'a montré de résidence à on
a ça dans notre adn
on a vécu plein de choses en allaient
depuis des siècles
depuis des siècles on est à un carrefour
de l'europe une zone où il ya eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de mouvements
beaucoup de choses difficiles on a je
suis sûr dans notre pays compte on se
parle entre nous et aujourd'hui et on a
la capacité de générosité de
collaboration et de résilience
collective aussi parce que quelque part
il ya un peu de résidences 1 on peut
plus vivre comme avant et je suis le
premier peiné de ne pas prendre
je pense que je prendrai mon papa dans
mes bras ce soir pour lui faire la bise
quand même
et voilà et sans masque évidemment mais
voilà et ça nous peine évidemment 2 on a
besoin aussi de ce lien social on a
besoin de ces manifestations là on a
besoin de vivre on pourra pas vivre
toute la vie avec des masques c'est sûr
on pourra pas vivre tout habitant
voyager on pourra pas vivre toute la
ville sans s'en retrouver le bonheur de
l' échange des restaurants des commerces
etc
il faut qu'on retrouve un moment se sont
installés pour l'instant pour l'instant
on n'en est pas là je rappelle qu'on est
des confits n'est que depuis kaddish
couvre donc pour l'instant le message et
on va se battre ensemble pour éliminer
ce virus s'il reste endémique on verra
et c'est la dernière partie je l'évoqué
avec vous c'est très bref très
brillamment ces thérapeutiques et max 1
on verra mais pour l'instant ces
reliques dernier point très rapide sait
où on en est sûr les traitements et des
vaccins pour être
r aujourd'hui pas traitement des montrer
efficace mais deux grandes pistes la
piste des traitements antiviraux il ya
plein de pistes
il ya des centaines et des centaines
d'études en cours avec des vieux
médicaments qu'on connaît déjà et des
nouveaux médicaments qu'on est en train
de découvrir
vous comprenez bien que les travaux sur
les anciens médicaments ça n'habitent
pas ce qu'ont ils sont déjà à
disposition
on peut les tester mais vite c'est pas
n'importe comment
on l'a dit a souvent attention à ne pas
passer de faux messages sur des anciens
médicaments en disant comme ils existent
il faut les utiliser
le problème c'est qu'il y en a des
centaines alors pourquoi l'or et pas
l'autre
je prends simplement vous avez un trois
exemples qui sont en finalement
comparable
c'est un peu technique mais je me
permets quand même cette chose technique
l'hydroxyde chloroquine dont on parle
beaucoup
la clope roma zink et le largue at-il
qu'on donne comme psychotropes à des
patients avec des problèmes
psychiatriques et l'ivermectine qui est
un antiparasitaire ces trois médicaments
qui n'ont rien à voir
tous les trois ont une activité
antivirale à peu près comparable alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on donnerait l'un et
pas l'autre
et pourquoi pas les trois ensemble ne
faut pas faire n'importe quoi donc même
avec les anciens médicaments
on a besoin de preuves parce qu'on a des
malades à soigner derrière et je
comprends le concept de jeu ne fait pas
de recherche mais je soigne mais soigné
c'est un engagement en essayant de
préserver nos patients puisque dans
chaque thérapeutiques ont prescrit il ya
un bénéfice et un risque et moi je ne
veux pas exposer mes malades à un risque
que je connais et que je ne connais pas
s'il n'y a pas de bénéfices en regard
voilà donc l'attitude est simple
aujourd'hui testo testions testions les
médicaments allons le plus vite possible
mais il faut un temps le temps de la
tante citoyenne et du patient elle est
compréhensible et elle est ultra courte
mais le temps de la démonstration il un
petit peu plus long on a gagné des moins
déjà sur la démonstration
il faut continuer dans cette voie là les
traitements
des formes graves évolue beaucoup des
traitements de ces malades qui arrivent
à l'hôpital en réanimation ses formes
vous savez hyper inflammatoires puisque
chez 10 à 15 % des malades infectés par
le comique 19
vous avez une explosion inflammatoires
ce qu'on appelle l'orage inflammatoires
et on ne sait d'ailleurs pas très bien
pourquoi les gens font 7 orange et
inflammatoires on sait qu'il est plus
fréquent avec l'âge il est plus fréquent
avec l'obésité et les plus fréquents
dans certaines circonstances cliniques
qu'on est en train de découvrir donc on
est en train de comprendre en fait cette
population ou qui est la plus grave
et imaginez qu'on trouve des traitements
pour éviter ces 10 à 15% de forme grave
on aura quasiment gagné la bataille
contre le virus parce que voilà s'il n'y
a plus ces patients si on sait les
traités et les contrôler ça sera presque
gagné le virus pourra continuer à
circuler mais on n'aura plus cette
encombrante système de santé dramatique
où il faut parfois malheureusement il
faudrait malheureusement faire des choix
pour les animations ce que je n'espère
pas voilà donc on travaille beaucoup
là-dessus il ya des travaux alsacien là
dessus on est très impliquée parce que
c'est un domaine brigitte connaît bien
notre domaine de prédilection que sont
les maladies inflammatoires et les
traitements une modulateurs donc sonné
on est très très en pointe là dessus on
essaie de contribuer à l'effort national
et international
j'espère qu'on apportera des choses
dernier sujet c'est les vaccins donc on
en a beaucoup parlé depuis 48 heures
sachez qu'aujourd'hui il y à déjà 8 ou 9
vaccins sont en phase d'études cliniques
chez l'homme ce qu'on appelle en phase
iii chez l'homme il ya quatre phases des
dents chez l'homme pour un médicament ou
vaccin il ya quatre phases 1 2 3 4
on est déjà en phase iii pour ou huit
axes à dire qu'on est en train de tester
sur les sommes déjà huit axes il en a il
y en a encore plus de j'ai regardé hier
soir puis 200 autres vaccins en
évaluation et on a trois en france à
l'institut pasteur et y en a dans les
entreprises évidemment française andean
développement en études mais là il faut
être assez humbles première chose on
n'est pas certain encore qu'on puisse
faire un axe un efficace et bien toléré
c'est vraisemblable mais ça n'est pas
certain l'om est d'ailleurs la rappeler
c'est quand même invraisemblable mais je
rappelle quand même qu'il y à des
épidémies virales contre lesquelles on
n'a jamais pu faire de vaccins vous
savez très bien aujourd'hui nature pas
de vaccin dont le sida qui tue
encore vous savez le sida qui a tué
entre 50 et 80 millions de personnes
depuis dans le monde depuis le début de
l'épidémie
donc on oublie n'oublions pas non plus
une aux autres et demi il ya d'autres
ennemis que le kobe mais sans état il ya
toujours pas de vaccin et l'hépatite c
je vous le rappelle dont on a payé un
lourd tribut quand même pendant des
années il n'y avait ni à jamais du
vaccin heureusement on a découvert des
traitements antiviraux qui guérissent
les malades d'aujourd'hui il n'ya jamais
de vaccins donc il ya des histoires
virale où on ne trouve pas de vaccin
mais ce sont surtout des virus chronique
là c'est un virus aiguë respiratoire
aiguë donc il ya de bonnes chances qu'on
découvre un vaccin
sachant que ce virus mute probablement
assez peu on a de bonnes chances que ce
vaccin soit suffisamment stable et
efficace pour protéger les populations
mais il ne faut rien attendre avant 2021
très raisonnablement ses 12 à 18 mois
et je crois qu'il faut être très
raisonnable à bac 5
ça s'étudie il faut que ça soit efficace
il faut que ce soit bien toléré on ne
fait pas les choses n'importe comment et
je crois que ça a été largement répété
on aura pas de vaccins avant début 2010
21 sauf magnifique surprise mais
franchement j'ai très étonné et tant
mieux alors tant mieux si j'ai tort tant
mieux mais je crois qu'il faudra
certainement attendre de 2021 et
j'espère que ce vaccin permettra de
traiter nos populations et à ce moment
là clairement de régler de régler le
compte de cet affreux virus qui
disparaîtra à ce moment là dedans nous
dans nos populations
donc voilà ce qu'on peut dire sur ce
troisième élément est évidemment pour
conclure vous avez compris que la
situation à venir
elle est incertaine je le répète en
conclusion parce que on ne connaît pas
bien encore l'histoire total de ce virus
et de la réponse immunitaire qu'il
induit chez les humains 2 les mesures
barrières on ne sait pas très bien
comment elles seront appliquées par nos
populations
mais j'étais très optimiste mais il ya
une incertitude sociologique sur
l'application de ces mesures barrières
j'espère qu'on fera ce qu'on est en
train de faire et qu'on tiendra le coup
mais c'est pas certain donc c'est une
variable incertaine quand même et 3
c'est la fameuse j'aime bien le terme
serendipity de la découverte de mesures
thérapeutiques vaccinale mais aussi eu
deux
découvertes médicales c'est la série
dépité c'est la certitude de ses
découvertes médicales conditionne
évidemment l'histoire de l'épidémie
si demain dans huit jours dans quatre
jours dans trois semaines on a un
antiviral efficace
magnifiquement efficace si on a des
traitement immunomodulateur qui empêche
leur âge inflammatoires chez les plus
graves et bien évidemment que l'histoire
ne sera pas la même donc ça c'est en
cours on guette on pourra faire un point
de route dans quelques semaines refaire
un point de route aujourd'hui on n'a pas
ces choses là mais on les attend et on
les attend avec un optimisme parce qu'il
ya un engagement des médecins et des
scientifiques comme jamais justifié
légitime donc on peut être optimiste sur
ce troisième voilà merci
brigitte merci à tout ça j'espère que je
vous ai fait un résumé le plus complet
le plus simple possible de d'une
actualité qui est très riche puisqu'il
ya eu plus de 10000 publications
scientifiques un pas dans paris match et
dans l'alsace ou dans les dna mes dents
dans les revues scientifiques plus de 10
mètres dix mille publication depuis le
début d'année ce qui montre l'engagement
mais massif de la science mondiale pour
essayer de résoudre ce set énorme épine
qu'on a dans le pied que j'espère qu'on
pourra retirer dans dans les mois dans
l'est - av voilà merci de m'avoir écouté
grand merci à monsieur le doyen
chargeant partager ses connaissances
on a envie de vous applaudir en effet
parce que vous le faites comme
d'habitude avec grande modestie et
beaucoup beaucoup d'humilité merci à
vous merci aussi d'avoir rappelé cette
chaîne de solidarité qui s'est mise en
place et plus particulièrement en alsace
et je crois pouvoir dire plus
particulièrement dans le haut rhin
nous étions une continuons à être tous
solidaires services de l'état
collectivités médecins soignants chefs
d'entreprises associations citoyens
comme vous le dites il faut pas oublier
faut que cette solidarité perdure parce
que c'est tous ensemble tous ensemble
qu'on arrivera à vaincre ce fléau
merci aussi d'avoir évoqué l'europe de
la santé comme vous je pense je suis
très triste de la fermeture des
frontières avec nos voisins
j'essaye de retenir ce qui s'est fait de
positif voire même de très positif en
matière de coopération transfrontalière
parce que la coopération transfontalière
vous l'avez évoqué à permet de sauver
des vies 1 il faut bien le dire et il
faut que après la crise on s'en
souviennent aussi et qu'on continue à
travailler
il ya développé encore le travail avec
nos voisins dans le domaine du bi
sanitaires d'ailleurs je pense vraiment
vraiment que la collectivité or plaine
d'alsace aura un rôle à jouer puisque
nous aurons un rôle à jouer
c'est la loi qui nous le dit dans le
schéma sanitaire transfrontaliers et
l'expérience montre que l'alsace était
l'échelle pertinente dans la gestion de
la crise et demain la politique
sanitaire pour à l'échelle de l'état que
des collectivités et bien dois je pense
être appréhendé à l'échelle de l'alsace
et la collectivité européenne d'alsace
devra avoir des compétences en la
matière je ne veux pas être plus longue
j'ouvre tout de suite les questions à
mes collègues et je vois qu eric
straumann à une question
eric straumann merci madame la
présidente seul professeur monsieur le
doyen je partage votre optimisme je
pense que pendant cette période
il faut éviter de 200 forme de
s'enfermer dans une vision pessimiste je
partage aussi une autre idée qu'il nous
faut pas rentrer dans un camp l'a fait
d'omettre de revanche mais quand même
pour le haut rhin il faudra s'interroger
sur ce qui s'est passé on a quand même
je crois 1400 morts dans notre
département s'est passé quelque chose au
début de la pandémie qui a échappé
notamment de notre organisation
administrative
je crois qu'il faudra se pencher sur
cette question et notamment du
dysfonctionnement c'est clair de la rs
avec la question des basques barrière je
partage complètement votre analyse est
là c'est un problème occidentale de haut
des bars ont considéré que du folklore
asiatique que de porter ces masques et
ça même imprégné un peu le personnel
politique français et le doute
aujourd'hui on se rend tout garder les
français ont un doute par rapport au
discours politique ça tient aussi au
discours qui a été tenue
rapport à l'utilité de ces masques je
crois qu'il peut jouer au maximum la
transparence et souffre est et expliquer
scientifiquement ce qui se déroule
devant nous alors depuis quelques jours
je jouais à colmar les laboratoires
proposent des tests de sérologie et des
gens s'y rendent ils sont pas remboursés
à 40 euros et ils se font tester autour
de moi puisque je suis très présent
appel marc autour de moi les gens sont
très souvent étonné par les résultats
vous avez madame qui était alité pendant
trois semaines qu'ils avaient de toute
évidence le coc vide sans avoir été
testé en tout cas tous les symptômes
elle est confinée pendant toute cette
période et ex-mari les deux seront
testés madame est positive l'hallali ggm
je crois ou gg pardon et monsieur est
négatif
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ça
mais alors c'est pas des situations
isolées et il ya des gens également
qu'ils étaient positives aux terres au
texte initial et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui dans ses tests de sérologie
comme négative alors est ce que ces
tests présente réellement un intérêt
ou alors est-ce que tout simplement
qu'au bout de deux ou trois mois ou deux
mois
certains qui ont été contaminés ya deux
mois est-ce que la protection en tout
cas la sérologie commença à disparaître
tout simplement et qu'il ya
éventuellement un risque de rechute à 7
à cet égard merci à vous merci excellent
question qui est un peu technique mais
je pense qu'elle est elle est
incontournable dans le contexte actuel
un parce que évidemment dont surtout
dans notre région
j'appellerai j'irai pardon je suis un
abus de langage jamais dans notre alsace
comme ça que j'éviterai la confusion est
en tout cas en alsace et dans la région
de l'épicentre de l'épidémie a donc haut
rhin bas rhin et odien en moselle au 6
mai a touché ces territoires
on a clairement besoin de savoir un
moment donné si les symptômes qu'on a
ressenti entre janvier et avril étaient
bien liées à l'infection par le col
alors une explication simple le plus
simple possible
c'est que pour savoir si on a été en
contact avec le virus
il y à la seule manière simple
aujourd'hui c'est de rechercher des
anticorps contre le virus par des tests
qu'on appelle les tests sérologiques
alors c'est très intéressant parce que
ça ne présume pas des symptômes que vous
avez fait or le coc vide
plus peut-être que d'autres virus
respiratoires peut ne se manifester par
aucun symptôme ou que des tout-petits 5
tourner en particulier chez les gens
jeunes et a fortiori chez les enfants
donc vous avez 8 vous avez été en
contact avec le virus
vous avez fait rien du tout ou parfois
24 heures de mots tête un peu de fric
sans envoyer ce qu'on fait dans une
grippe
et pourtant vous avez été en contact
alors il ya plein de gens qui ont eu des
symptômes dans les trois derniers mois
mais ça c'est normal c'est la période
hivernale
vous savez que dans cette période
hivernale le syndrome grippal est une
banalité absolue
donc c'est ma première mon premier
élément de réponse c'est beaucoup de
gens ont eu des symptômes pendant cette
période là des symptômes on dit peu
spécifique c'est-à-dire mal à la tête de
la fièvre des douleurs etc
mais ces dessins tourner qu'on peut voir
avec des dizaines et des dizaines et des
dizaines de virus et pas que le colis de
19 donc la première explication
évidemment c'est que tous ces gens qui
se soit sentie malade un petit peu
pendant cette période là bas ils n'ont
pas être colis qu'ils ont eu autre chose
donc ça c'est une explication la
deuxième explication et donc on ne
trouve pas d'anticorps contre coco la
deuxième explication les plus techniques
c'est que les tests sérologiques on
utilise aujourd'hui non pas une
sensibilité absolue ils n'ont pas de
sens si petit absolue c'est à dire on
estime la sensibilité entre 85 et 90 %
ça veut dire que même si vous avez été
infectés par le co lead si la
sensibilité n'est que de 85 à 90% il ya
10 à 15 % de chances que le test ne soit
pas capable de détecter les anticorps
pour des raisons purement techniques si
vous voulez donc ça c'est une deuxième
explication la troisième explication
on est en train de l'affiner c'est que
la réponse immunitaire de chacun et et
est différente et on a observé notamment
que les sujets qui ont fait peu de
symptômes ou pas de symptômes et qui ont
eu un virus un frotter avec le le test
positif
donc ça a été démontré à shanghai et
dans une diatribe sud
vous avez le virus ou est certain mais
quand on regarde la réponse anticorps
deux trois semaines il faut pas regarder
avant parce que les anticorps mais deux
trois semaines à paraître c'est aussi un
élément d'explication important mais si
vous regardez à la bonne période de
trois semaines après et bien vous n'avez
pas fait d'anticorps détectables et
effectivement il ya 30 % de gens jeunes
qui ont fait des formes minimes qui ne
développe pas d'anticorps on ne sait pas
pourquoi mes derniers commentaires ça ne
veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont pas fait de
réponse immunitaire
donc on est en train de d'étudier dans
les familles exactement ce que vous
décrivez dans les familles un membre a
fait un coup vite certains avec un test
pcr positive et intel sérologies
positives et les autres n'ont pas fait
mais ont eu des symptômes et on regarde
les anticorps ils n'en n'ont pas donc on
essaie de voir si ces gens là ont quand
même une autre réponse immunitaire mais
on est en train de voir que ces gens
s'ils n'ont pas d'anticorps ils ont
quand même une réponse immunitaire
différentes contre le virus mais ça ça
n'est que de la recherche aujourd'hui
c'est une analyse de recherche
il n'y a pas de tests encore dans les
laboratoires je finis en vous disant que
évidemment les tests faits dans les
laboratoires aujourd'hui sont non
remboursés mais que la chasse la haute
autorité de santé a promis sous huit ou
dix jours de donner des recommandations
sur les tests rapides fait par les
moteurs de bill et de donner des
recommandations de validation de ces
tests est donc d'accorder le
remboursement
donc on aura assez rapidement une
recommandation nationale après
comparaison de tous les tests des bons
tests des moins bons et d'un
remboursement de certains sur
prescription médicale
il faudra le faire sur prescription
médicale donc on aura évidemment très
rapidement maintenant des éléments
supplémentaires et on pourra peut-être
mieux utiliser les tests comme le fait
aujourd'hui
merci pour eux merci beaucoup
nous avons encore madame vallat qui aura
une question à vous poser
marie-france falla oui oui merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup aux professeurs
6 milliards pour votre exposé qui a été
tout à fait clairs et et qui a bien
détaillé les mesures barrières à
respecter je voudrais vous demander à
titre personnel mais je pense que ça
intéresse beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui puis du comportement en
famille lorsqu effectivement il ya des
personnes qui sont en proximité des
soignants mais encore toutes les autres
personnes qui sont à proximité de
malades
que faire et pour moi c'est une
inquiétude personnel je pense qu'à
l'aide doit être partagée avec beaucoup
de d'autres d'autres personnes et que
fait-on aujourd'hui nous sommes enfin
souvent dans la tranche d'âge des
personnes fragiles
au delà de 60 ans que fait-on dans le
milieu familial comment respectons ces
mesures barrière est ce que qu'est-ce
que c'est un porteur sain est ce que
finalement à soignants ou une personne
qui en contact avec les malades
peut-être un porteur sain et transmettre
virus sans en être lui-même conscient
voilà enfin je trouve que autant dans
l'espace public on peut respecter
facilement ou au moins relativement
facilement les consignes autant dans le
cercle familial ça devient bon train en
particulier ça devient plus qu'aux plus
compliqué donc j'apprécierais beaucoup
d'avoir des conseils dans ce domaine
merci beaucoup
oui c'est une très bonne question que je
sorte comme il ya encore d'autres
questions d' attaques toutes les prendre
pour les remous ok d'accord comment on
peut les regrouper peut-être hockey
pouvoir vous vous libérer c'est une très
bonne question sur la protection
intrafamiliales vous avez raison ok là
il y à madame fatima yens et madame
karine pagliarulo qui on est question ma
des revenus dans la rue donc bonjour
professeur utile pour cet exposé fort
intéressant écoutez mes deux questions
sont vraiment direct
est ce que les personnes qui ont déjà eu
locaux dit dimanche peuvent encore la
voir et la deuxième question pour la
ville nous est-ce que vous avez par
exemple connaissance des nombres de cas
nouveaux locaux vides
récemment après le col de déconfinement
merci beaucoup
si madame bagués rouleau
oui vous m'entendez oui bonjour
compresseur merci pour ce très bel
exposé et cette belle leçon aussi pour
permettre à tous d'avoir d'être sur la
même voie sur la même lignée juste deux
interrogations
moi j'ai remarqué vous l'avez souligné
la solide la solidarité pardon
territoriale et surtout les fameuses
hôpitaux de proximité qui ont vraiment
joué leur jeu dans cette crise et qui
ont pu aussi aider nos concitoyens dans
la proximité une juste une question qui
concerne les enfants parce que vous
l'avez pas évoquer à l'heure où les
écoles réouvre et ont beaucoup beaucoup
d'interrogations vient de tours de cette
population ou les moins de 6 ans le sait
ne peuvent pas porter quel est votre
avis à ce sujet qu'elle est qu'est-ce
qui pourrait apporter aux parents pour
peut-être les les accompagner dans cette
dynamique vers le scolaire qui est quand
même importante aussi on l'a compris
voilà merci merci beaucoup à la je crois
qu'on a pris toutes les questions je
vérifie professeur si des liens alors
3,3 excellente question
on va les prendre dans l'ordre 1 sur la
protection de familiale
c'est une vraie question très compliquée
je trouve qui a été assez peu débattu en
d'autres termes en famille on est proche
en famille il est très compliqué
d'appliquer des mesures barrières on
marche pas avec le masque le soir autour
de la table par définition donc c'est
assez compliqué et ça dans toutes
circonstances
et comme vous le rappeliez on a des
sujets asymptomatiques qui portent le
virus et qui peuvent être contagieux
c'est démontrer mais on sait aussi et
c'est une particularité malheureusement
dû qu'ovide qu on est contagieux avant
d'être malade ce qui n'est pas le cas de
la grippe par exemple on ne devient
contagieux que quand on commence à voir
la fièvre et les premiers symptômes
donc le problème et on est contagieux 2
enfin un à trois jours avant le début
des symptômes
donc en fait il ya des tas de situations
où on a l'impression que la vie est tout
à fait normal mais qu' il y as au sein
de la famille quelqu'un qui peut porter
le virus
je le répète soit avant les symptômes
soit parce qu'ils les porteurs
asymptomatiques
donc ça pose un vrai problème dans les
familles alors que faire g
solution miracle mais je ne parle pas de
la situation où le membre un membre
infecté d'une famille est confiné en
intra familiales puisque vous savez
comme l'a dit le premier ministre si un
sujet est dépisté positif
il peut choisir d'être ou à l'hôtel ou
en famille mais j'ai n'ai pas bien
compris et je suis pas le seul et il
faut qu'on en débatte à ce moment là est
ce qu'on il est confiné en famille est
ce qu'à ce moment là ont toute la
famille considérait comme confinés
pendant la même période
décalé de quelques jours de fête puisque
la contamination
koster ça devient un truc très compliqué
à gérer un ou est ce que la famille qui
vit avec le contaminer est susceptible
de sortir et je pense que c'est une
vraie question extrêmement difficile
donc voilà posé une question difficile
moi les conseils c'est des conseils
d'hygiène de base pour limiter les
choses c'est quand on rentre à la maison
a fortiori quand on est dans une famille
où il ya un soignant fautes et ses
chaussures il faut se immédiatement se
laver les mains avoir déjà moi je le
fais je me mets du gel hydroalcoolique
quand je sors de ma voiture parce que
j'imagine peut-être que j'ai mis du
virus sur le volant alors il ne
perdurera pas mais il est peut-être là
je sors de la voiture je me fais je me
lave bien les mains au gel
hydroalcoolique avant de rentrer chez
moi j'ose mais ce chemin chaussures et
encore aujourd'hui je me déshabille
voilà je me change avec un évidement en
mettant une tenue de maisons de deux
soirées en ayant pris je le fais encore
aujourd'hui en ayant pris une douche
pour se laver se laver les cheveux donc
alors c'est bien c'est des mesures
d'hygiène mais on est soigné ont donc
que moi j'suis soignants mais ces
mesures là elle peut être transposé à la
vie intra familiales toutes mesures
d'hygiène que vous pouvez prendre sont
bonnes
après qu'est ce qu'on peut faire au delà
c'est à dire le soir avant de se coucher
est-ce qu'on se fait une petit business
concernant les bras est ce qu'on vient
pas je crois qu'il faut continuer à
vivre il faut surtout pas dans une
psychose hypocondriaque permanente de
puces regarder tous touchés d'avoir peur
de l'autre il faut arriver à vie mais le
fait de se laver les mains de faire très
attention de d'éviter des
des éléments contaminants venant de
l'extérieur c'est déjà une bonne chose
si on fait déjà tout ça je pense que ce
sera bien et vous concourrez continuer à
vous prendre dans les bras et à vous
faire un petit bisou le soir mais voilà
c'est il n'y a pas de mesure absolument
idéal
deuxième question très bonne question
j'ai fait à coville est ce que je peux
refaire un call it
la réponse est non aujourd'hui rien ne
permet de dire qu'on peut recycler du
coc vide dans les semaines ou les mois
qui suivent il ya aucune observation de
de rechute ou vous ré attraper le colis
ça c'est un élément extrêmement
intéressant ça veut dire que toutes
choses égales par ailleurs quand on a
fait une réponse immunitaire contre le
coc vide on la garde au moins quelques
semaines quelques mois je sais pas si on
la regardera des années mais on l'a bien
quelques mois au moins et ça a été
parfait dans démontré sur des
expériences chez les singes déjà une un
article scientifique très intéressant ou
des sages ont été infectées ont fait une
réponse immunitaire au co vides et les
expérimentateurs essaye de les
réaffecter au co lead et n'y arrive pas
donc ça c'est plutôt ration donc
aujourd'hui on peut penser qu' il n'y a
pas de rechute possible du coc vide
en tout cas aucune démonstration est
évidemment surveille ça de très près on
verra dans les prochaines semaines les
prochains mois mais c'est plutôt une
donnée ration dernières données dernière
question évidemment c'est sûr les
enfants qu'elles sont très importants
parce que l'école a repris partiellement
on a appris beaucoup de choses sur les
enfants ça c'est très intéressant
puisqu'on pensait que comme dans la
grille que les enfants étaient un
réservoir est un réservoir de contagion
majeur du virus
c'est le vrai pour la grippe ça n'est
pas vrai pour qu vite mais attention ne
de bascule non pas le message
les enfants sont porteurs du virus 1 ils
peuvent être porteurs mais 2,2
considération importante
ils portent le virus probablement de
façon un peu moins importante que les
adultes
donc ils sont à l'évidence moins
contagieux des adultes ça c'est un point
très important mais moins contagieux ne
veut pas dire pas contagieux donc
attention donc ça veut dire que quand
vous regrouper des enfants dans le bac à
sable à l'école il faut faire quand même
attention parce que cd regroupant deux
collectifs
donc les enfants qu'elles se contaminer
quand même et contaminer les adultes
mais c'est beaucoup plus rare que dans
l'autre sens ce qu'on a observé plus tôt
aujourd'hui
ce sont les adultes qui contaminent des
enfants plutôt que les enfants qui ont m
mais l'autre sens c'est possible aussi
donc attention mais ils sont très peu
contagieux et deuxième chose je peux
vous confirmer malgré les messages qu'on
entend les enfants font très très très
peu de symptômes est très très rarement
des formes graves
il y en a mais c'est exceptionnel
exceptionnel mais malheureusement il y
en a mais c'est vraiment exceptionnel
pour être rassurés donc ces deux
éléments
je pense qu'ils sont très claires on n'a
pas répondu à toutes les questions
encore les enfants font-ils des
anticorps combien de temps porte-t-il le
virus porte-t-il le virus plutôt dans
les selles que dans les voies
respiratoires
il ya des tas de questions qui vont se
résoudre mais globalement ils sont peu
contagieux et ils sont vraiment à peu de
risque de formes graves
ça c'est plutôt rassurant donc je crois
que poser la question que l'expérience
qu'on va mener là pendant quelques
semaines de l'école avant les vacances
elle est intéressante il faut il vaut
mieux ça je crois moi j'y crois
profondément
il vaut mieux tester le modèle
maintenant dans des conditions de
sécurité maximale pour être prêt en
septembre
parce qu'en septembre la situation sera
plus la même donc on a besoin
tous les renseignements qu'on peut
obtenir dans une retour à la vie sociale
et la vie scolaire pendant le mois de
mai le mois de juin ne sera très très
utile à tous pour savoir ce qu'il faut
faire en septembre
imaginez que l'on fasse rien maintenant
je moi je ne sais pas comment il faut
ouvrir en septembre
médicalement médicalement je ne sais pas
alors on apprendra des choses dans
l'intervalle y aura peut-être une
deuxième vague ou pas on apprendra des
trucs mais c'est quand même très
intéressant de voir ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
pendant ces quelques semaines avant les
vacances les grandes vacances et on
ouvrira mieux les écoles en 70 avec plus
de sécurité moins d'inquiétude peut-être
je l'espère on verra et des mesures qui
seront des mesures probalement adapté à
la période de la rentrée
donc je crois que c'est important vous
avez posé une dernière question j'ai
oublié mais je l'avais noté
vous demandez le taux de circulation du
virus en alsace et à nous
je ne vais pas précisément parce qu'il
faut le regarder un jour par ge you pour
l'instant les remontées de terrain c'est
qu'il ya toujours des infections
qu'ovide qui arrive aux urgences il en a
toujours deux détectés chaque jour donc
il n'ya pas d'extinction de la diffusion
du virus
il y a toujours deux du passage
interhumains de virus sasser ainsi quand
même à l'arrêt
girls the lady est optimisé rigueur
s'est sali mais il faut être rigoureux
le virus circule encore dans notre dans
notre alsace aussi bien dans le roi que
dans le bas-rhin donc l'épidémie n'est
pas fille et vous avez posé la question
évidemment en j'avais oublié d'en parler
mais des des recommandations qu'il
faudra prendre est proposée à l'issue de
l'analyse de tout ça parce que
effectivement le haut-rhin a été touchée
de façon incroyable il ya eu la
lombardie il ya eu le haut rhin il ya
quelques régions en europe y en a pas
beaucoup
quand vous regardez les choses alors
l'angleterre et à part évidemment et
puis ya des régions où il ya rien eu
évidemment on aura besoin d'une
compréhension de cette hétérogénéité ça
c'est quand même très particulier
il ya des choses quand même que
aujourd'hui on a du mal à comprendre
il ya des pays comme la grèce la
roumanie la slovaquie où il ya quasiment
rien eu
en cela qui a eu 20 morts vous rendez
compte et il y en a il y en a mille
quatre cent mille cinq cents sur le sur
le seul département du haut rhin
donc il ya certainement mais dans une
approche médico-scientifique pas du tout
dans une approche de revendications
revancharde
mais dans une analyse médico
scientifique et épidémiologique je pense
qu'il ya vraiment il faut vraiment qu'on
comprenne pourquoi cet écart gigantesque
quand même de d'épidémie ça il faut
absolument qu'on le comprenne on a des
indices mais fera qu'on l'analyse de
façon détaillée
je ne suis pas épidémiologie c'est pas
moi qui le ferait mais il ya des il ya
des gens qui travailleront évidemment
j'espère que j'ai répondu à tous merci
monsieur le professeur si vous avez
encore deux minutes il ya une toute
dernière question d'être son collègue
madame groff à la parole bernadette
groff merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur le professeur de nous accorder
de votre temps deux petites questions
dans un premier temps le sérum vous
parlez du ceran pour traiter les
patients
ce serment a été très utilisé dès le
départ chez nous voisins suisses entre
autres chez nous il me semble que non et
deuxièmement que pensez vous de la
polémique ça nourrit avec cette
production de proximité qui pourrait se
faire chez nous alors sur la polémique
va jouer je vais être très clair cette
polémique n'est pas entendable enfin et
je pense que là c'est une décision
éminemment politique que les politiques
prendront c'est pas une décision
médicale enfin la position du médecin
elle est extrêmement simple
s'il ya un vaccin il doit être
accessible pour tous mais à l'évidence
et pas pour un seul pays et pas pour une
seule population et il doit être
accessible en priorité gratuitement pour
les plus précaires et les plus fragiles
safarian aucune discussion médical
possible
voilà c'est la ligne par pagesjaunes
mais c'est la ligne rouge
ça se discute même pas enfin c'est cette
discussion elle n'est pas entendable
enfin je pense que brigitte partagent
certainement point de vue on peut pas
entendre cette discussion là et là là là
toute façon c'est pas les experts c'est
pas nous qui avons la main notre réponse
elle est très claire et je pense qu'elle
sera absolument unanime
après c'est une discussion qui est
éminemment politique et je pense que les
politiques entendront ce message
donc j'ai répondu à ça et la question de
la plus technique de la ce qu'on appelle
la sérothérapie c'est à dire donnez-les
anticorps des anticorps de convalescent
à des gens malades est une vieille
technique d'ailleurs il faut rappeler
que ça a été utilisé par les élèves de
pasteur à l'époque de la diphtérie donc
voyez il ya bien longtemps et à l'époque
on ne connaissait même pas les anticorps
on savait pas ce qu'on vous aime et on
donnait déjà du sérum de convalescent à
d a dit jean manade et on a sauvé
notamment charles nicolle qui a sauvé a
été très célèbre procès approche cas
donc céder via les approches mais en
fait il faut les valides et quand même
on peut pas vous savez on tombe pas du
sérum du sang d'un malade et on le donne
à l'autre parce que on peut pas donner
le sens de quelqu'un à n'importe qui il
ya des compatibilités 1
ne serait-ce que liés à des groupes
sanguins à d'autres choses qui fait que
les anticorps qu'on prélève on doit les
purifier on doit les préparer et on doit
vérifier qu'on ne fait pas de bêtise
donc ça a été fait il ya plusieurs
centaines même il y est je crois
maintenant de gens dans le monde qui ont
été traités par ça ça marche c'est pas
là c'est pas une baguette magique mais
c'est très intéressant
ç'a permis clairement de réduire la
mortalité des formes graves
alors on a utilisé le sens de des
patients alsacien prélevés dans les
banques de sang en notamment de
strasbourg parce que je sais que nos
passions ont aidé à ça mais après on est
encore je le rappelle on n'est pas dans
d'utilisation quotidienne
on est encore dans des utilisations dans
le cas de protocole thérapeutique
donc ça c'est vraiment très important
une fois que ça sera validé la mesure
pourra se diffuser mais merci pour la
question qui est très technique mais qui
est très intéressant voilà merci de tout
coeur d'avoir répondu à nos questions
chercheur jean sibilia nos collègues
étaient d'ailleurs très nombreux ce
matin a participé à la séance
preuve aussi de l'intérêt qu'ils avaient
à vous écouter
merci aussi aux journalistes qui ont été
avec nous ce matin voudrais vous dire
pour terminer cher jean monsieur loyal
combien nous sommes fiers d'avoir en
alsace des personnalités des experts
engagés comme vous c'est vraiment
vraiment une
une fierté pour l'alsace et puis au nom
de tous les collègues si vous le
permettez un joyeux anniversaire à votre
papa merci de tout pas leurrer et à très
vite a très vite beaucoup au revoir jean
chers collègues bonne journée à tous au
revoir